from daring motorcycle stunts to holding
his breath underwater for six minutes
Tom Cruise will do anything for a roll
but when you are going without stunt
doubles as often as possible something's
bound to go wrong like the time Emily
Blunt said I almost killed Tom Cruise on
the set of Edge of Tomorrow these are
the 100 million box office movies that
Tom gave his all on
Mission Impossible Fallout brought in a
whopping
791.1 million but the stunt Tom
remembers most is the easy one where I
I'm running and I jump from one building
to the next Tom was chasing Henry Cavill
across rooftops and although he was
meant to hit the side of the wall the
mistake was when his foot landed dude I
knew instantly he was broken
and he's running Tom didn't want to do
the take again so while another actor
would have given up there Abby gets and
he's running the moment Tom broke his
ankle is actually in the movie we see
why Emily Blunt finds him inspiring but
after the take was done so was Tom I
just swear I said sorry guys it's broken
you know take me to the hospital it just
wasn't gonna stop him from finishing the
movie it's not fully healed but we're
shooting we hope that 370.5 million they
made on this was worth it as we've
mentioned Emily Blunt was impressed by
I'm on set he really does everything and
wants to do everything even if the stunt
guys and the producers are like please
don't do that he even made her want to
do her own stunts for the movie One
stunt had Emily driving this crazy old
car with Tom in the passenger seat and
the next thing she knew Tom goes oh God
and break break
the car break the car but Emily thought
she knew more about stunt driving than
him and I left it too late and so drove
us into a tree there was a moment where
Emily thought and I almost killed Tom
Cruise but he was all right I was just
laughing and he was actually laughing he
wouldn't be so lucky on Mission
Impossible 3. you saw him work through
plenty of pain for that 398 million box
office Tom cracked six ribs doing one
stunt for Mission Impossible 3. he was
put in this massive rig that twisted his
body around and it twisted it too hard
and that was it but just like with his
broken ankle this wouldn't stop him
another stunt involved his character
running away from missiles and Tom
wasn't just gonna fall down he wanted to
make the scene more interesting so he
worked with stunt coordinator Vic
Armstrong to have a system of Riggs
throw him into a car with the force of
the explosion I'm admitted it hurts but
going back to Emily Blunt for a moment
she's the only co-star to have worried
they killed Tom onset that's right Jamie
Foxx also got in a little fender bender
with Tom on the set of this 220 million
Motion Picture Jaime was playing a taxi
driver against Tom who played an
assassin and at one point Jamie lost
control of his cab and drove it straight
into Tom's Mercedes the Mercedes was
lifted off the ground and flew offset
Tom later said that the entire time I
was hitting the roof I was down on the
ground it was brilliant Jamie noticed
that the crew rushed to check on Tom
before him saying they were so worried
that I killed my man can you imagine all
that money bouncing around in the back
seat and can you imagine all that money
almost beheaded for The Last Samurai oh
it happened The Last Samurai brought in
456 million worldwide and Tom nearly
gave his all for it there was one scene
that had Tom and his co-star Hiro Yuki
Sonata approaching one another on
mechanical forces hiroyuki was supposed
to stop a split second before he swung
his sword for Tom's head except the
mechanism failed and hiroyuki kept going
later saying the film crew watching from
the side all screamed because they
thought Tom's head would fly off
fortunately hiroyuki has trained martial
arts his horse hit Tom but he was able
to stop the sword mere inches away from
his neck did a great job today mom
hadn't really been afraid because he
trusted hiroyuki plus he's used to
getting plenty of bumps and bruises from
the Mission Impossible movies now the
first mission impossible movie set the
tone for the franchise not only did it
make
457.7 million worldwide but the stunts
were seriously Next Level the exploding
fish tank scene is one of our all-time
favorites but Tom knew that if he was
standing in the wrong place when the
thousand gallon tanks blew I'm really
gonna get hurt Tom hears the first tank
explode and it takes everything in my
power to stay standing there until he
receives his cue Tom started running as
soon as he did saying and it was a wall
of water and chunks of glass Tom walked
away with little more than a bruised
angle while another stunt man had a gash
leg well hey at least it gave him a
break from car crashes Tom learned the
hard way not to add Flair to a stunt
even if the movie brings in 157.9
million NASCAR vet hot Strickland
trained Tom in racing cars for Days of
Thunder Tom has experienced flying
planes from Top Guns so driving was a
piece of cake but there was one day when
they were filming at a track 24 miles
west of Daytona Beach and Hut felt that
Tom didn't really know what I was
talking about Tom had seen guys on TV
squirming back and forth left and right
but when he did it the car spun out and
grazed a wall luckily Tom wasn't going
very fast but too bad he had to kill a
hundred thousand dollar camera strand to
the side of his vehicle now Top Gun
helped turn Tom into a household name it
made 357 million at the box office but
according to Barry Tubb Cruz came as
close to dying as anybody on set I've
ever seen it was during the scene where
Maverick and Goose Parachute from their
plane Tom nearly sank to the bottom of
the ocean fortunately one of the Frog
men in the chopper saw his parachute
ballooning out and they were able to
save him but that isn't the only problem
Tom had we are moving around and like
did nine and a half G's and very hard in
my body he had to keep a vomit bag on
hand because the pressure could get so
bad my head was literally from the
pressure it was my head was on the
ground but Tom survived just to risk his
life again on Rogue Nation Top Gun
couldn't scare Tom away from either the
water or the air no more than Oblivion
scared him from motorcycles Mission
Impossible Rogue Nation brought in
683 million worldwide and a blockbuster
this big deserves some big stunts like
the time Tom was strapped to the outside
of an Airbus a400m in Flight with
nothing but a safety harness he was
moving so fast that even a bird or a
small Stone could hit Tom with deadly
force but it was all okay he was just
laughing and giving
another scene had Tom holding his breath
underwater for six whole minutes
normally in underwater sequences people
hold their breath for 10 seconds 15
seconds Max Palm really had to go out of
his way to prove he could do it safely
before they'd allow him to do it and we
can't believe he did all right so how
cool was Tom's motorcycle in Oblivion we
know it wasn't what brought in the 286
million at the box office but Justin
Kell at glory Motor Works definitely did
the trick when it came to transforming a
regular dirt bike into something
futuristic but there was one stunt Tom
did on the motorbike that almost went
terribly wrong he lost control of the
bike after flying up a ramp at top speed
it just barely missed his leg but
moments later Tom can be seen with his
hands up promising it's all right guys
he's used to these sort of Mistakes by
now still Tom had a blast riding it so
much so that he was even given a version
of the bike for his 50th birthday which
he celebrated on set Ghost Protocol was
definitely worth the
694.7 million name do you remember the
scene where Ethan Hunt scaled the side
of a
2722 foot skyscraper to reach the 130th
floor well did you know that Tom was
actually hanging off the side of the
world's tallest building yeah this one
in Dubai what do you think was going
through his mind before he did it as Tom
simply put it hope I don't fall
considering how often stunts go wrong
for poor Tom you may be surprised to
hear that he pulled off his Daredevil
moves without a hitch but he's no
stranger to Heights he even climbed a
similar height for Mission Impossible 2.
now this movie had one of the greatest
openings ever this
546.4 million box office movie starts
with Tom actually free climbing through
the Cliffs of dead horse point in Utah
the scary thing was the crate was 2 000
feet high there wasn't even any
protection on the ground Eva no Tom
would have to jump
the strawberry scam here so I I was
sweating and I could panic but Tom
didn't necessarily share director John
Rue's concerns I felt very confident
with the team we had and uh I felt
confident that I could do it he'd even
go so far as to say that was the most
fun that I've had probably on the entire
picture it isn't hard to see why these
movies did so well when you consider the
lengths Tom is willing to go to we're
just glad he hasn't been too seriously
injured minus puparuz who's in a broken
ankle so which of these stunts did you
find could be the most impressive and
were there any other examples from Tom
we might have missed don't forget to let
us know down in the comment section